but you have spoken to a porn star yeah
who has today's I gonna be asking my
direct questions under a lie-detector
I've been pretty honest with my son and
I hope he's been honest with me it's
because I didn't really ask you any
questions given that he is my stepson I
am a little concerned with what the
truth might be Adam have you ever
skipped school yeah
he's telling the truth did you do this
in high school yeah he's telling the
truth first question I'm gonna keep it
simple have you been drinking enough
water yes he's telling the truth
have you ever hung out with someone that
I didn't like yes true who was that guy
well there are some rebels and then you
told me not to hang out with bad people
and there happen to be smoking memory
yeah and they offered me something I
said no thank you
when I asked you to do something for me
and you told me you needed the money to
pay a bill did you spend that money on a
bill yes not true have you taken any
illegal substances within the last two
weeks no he's lying when I asked you to
reorganize the garage they happen to be
Halloween costumes that you really
really really really liked did you take
them
no it's a lie-detector test
they were so cute though
[Music]
did you quit your job or did you get
fired
I quit doing bad for your house sex with
friend of yours no crew
why not Stephanie I really want to ask
you this for a long time - I'm nervous
when I baked cookies for your sister's
birthday party literally half of them
came up missing that your cousin Mike
came over at a them but I never saw Mike
come in ever did you beat those yes I
did
that's true I wish he'd baked my cookies
have you had any sexual relations yes
true was any of this unprotected by any
chance yeah
he's telling the truth oh great mom's
gonna love this no no she's not oh yes
yes me being your stepmom you know I
don't feel the family vibe when I'm
around you try to cover it up a lot so
does your biological mom like your
stepmom yes or no yes yeah see I told
you I did I gotta cook some more cookies
have you ever had any relations with a
porn star no crew I've ever spoken to a
porn star yeah crew so let's hear about
so we have a date - for the fraternity
agents a porn star
yeah saying he's lying I was going Mia
are you dating now No
[Music]
mmm having a tough time
[Music]
oh we're just talking and sometimes I go
to sleep or in the morning just talking
to him he has a girlfriend that's bad so
today we just finished the lie detector
test with my stepson and a Roman found
out some very interesting things about
my son he actually has had some kind of
conversation with a porn star that I
didn't know about it should be very
interesting to hear more about as we
drive home it was a great experience
because we know each other but with this
this it came out great I respect him and
hope he respects me too I respect you
dad
stop lying
[Music]